welcome everybody to
the genomics virtual week of 2020
my name is matthew ferber and i am
a clinical laboratory director in the
department of lab medicine and pathology
here at the mayo clinic
i am a clinical molecular geneticist by
training
and today i would like to talk to you
about population health and genetic
testing
again thank you for joining us i hope
everybody is staying
safe and practicing social distancing
this is a fantastic venue for us to
learn share and of course remain
appropriately distant from one another
in these challenging times so
thank you for joining us and i look
forward to speaking with you throughout
the next
30 minutes or so
i'm going to start off with just a
couple of disclosures not
nothing to spend a lot of time on here
but it's important that as we go through
the descriptions
of population health studies that mayo
clinic and others are engaged in
we are working on those studies in
collaboration
with a for-profit laboratory by the name
of helix
helix is a for-profit company mayo
clinic has a small investment within the
c sequencing technology of that
laboratory but none of our employees
have a financial interest
within the company okay
housekeeping out of the way i really
like to organize the talk into four
different sections
we're going to bring up the beginning
with a background and information about
basic population health and it will
describe how or whether or not genetic
testing actually fits in
to population health strategies i'll try
to demonstrate that through some
interesting examples and then towards
the end of the talk we'll open it up for
some discussion or at least i'll provide
some discussion
and then you can hit me back with any
questions
through email after the after the talk
is over
so what is population health if you take
of just a strict
dictionary definition of population
health
it comes down to the global study of
health outcomes
in a divine defined cohort of
individuals
but the world health organization in
1946
took a much broader view of population
health
and they said that it's not just the
complete physical
but it's also the mental and social
well-being
and not merely the absence of disease or
infirmity
that's important when considering
population health initiatives
the form that we're most familiar with
takes the form of
more population health management this
is how
large providers or insurance payers
manage their overall population a
significant number being very healthy
and another significant proportion
having some sort of disease
which of course costs that provider a
lot of money to
help treat so they use different tools
and strategies to help manage that
population
so that they can spread their costs
spread their efficacy towards the
the best population to um to affect the
best health outcomes
i think we're all familiar with a number
of different population health
initiatives if we just take a step back
and think a little bit more broadly
newborn screening has been around
for many years we know how what a
significant positive impact this has had
on the health of the globe the united
states for sure
phenylketonuria or pku used to be a
disorder that
children died at a fairly early age
without much understanding for why but
now with newborn screening we're able to
identify those individuals
before they become symptomatic and begin
treating them
and they live long healthy lives same
can be said for sickle cell anemia and
cystic fibrosis all wrapped up into
newborn screening protocols we now have
expanded newborn screening that varies
by state and
over a hundred different conditions at
times can be screened for within these
public health initiatives all trying to
improve the health
of that cohort
other examples include hiv screening or
neural tube defect screening in
expectant mothers
especially mothers of advanced maternal
age
we're in the the the current pandemic
scenario right now so we may expect at
some point
once we are able to gear up testing that
covid19
testing or other infectious agents may
become population health initiatives
so that we can better the health of the
nation and of the world
and then a lesser known probably not to
this
audience but if we were talking with a
lay audience a lesser-known population
health initiative just launched
in 2015 was the
all of us study launched by then
president barack obama
who said tonight i'm launching a new
precision medicine initiative
to bring us closer to curing disease
diseases like cancer and diabetes
i think the the real motivating factor
behind this is
with over a decade and a half almost two
decades since
the sequencing of the human genome we
still struggle to really take full
advantage
of the power of that genome information
and so by announcing this public health
initiative
all of us president obama really
envisioned
sequencing over a million united states
citizens
from vast different backgrounds and
ethnicities in order to compile that
data
in a way that would teach us how we can
use
genetic information in everyday health
in order to
better the globe's population health
initiatives
i don't want to brag too much but i'm
very proud to say that the mayo clinic
actually is the biobanking facility for
the all of us study
and as of 2019 at the close of 2019 i
should say
we had well over 175 000 participant
samples
already received on site and from those
samples we make multiple different
sample sub aliquots of different types
blood serum plasma
all of that stuff we have over four and
a half million individual
specimens banked in support of the all
of us initiative
so that's a basic background on
population health
let's talk a little bit then about how
genetic testing can be used
in population health initiatives we know
that genetic testing the cost of genetic
testing continues to go down
so how do we leverage these now powerful
tools
that our expensive than they used to be
in a way that helps us to cost
effectively improve
the overall quality and care of the
population
if i were to restate that as a question
the answer to the question would be
yes we're ready to go but the follow-up
question
very quickly is and should be
where do we start we know that the human
genome
is comprised of over 20 000 genes some
of those genes
relatively few we know a lot about and
we know how they impact your health
the vast majority we know have some type
of function but it's unclear
how they actually impact your health
status so where do we start
we start with what we know it's quite
simple
now the center for disease control and
prevention created a statement
a couple of years ago about population
health
and population health genetics
specifically it's not a full endorsement
of population genetics but it is a
statement about the types of disorders
where
we feel and they feel the
scientific community and healthcare
community could have the largest impact
this list has been compiled and is now
known as
the cdc tier one genomic applications
and in the link that i've provided below
in the slide that you're looking at
right now it will take you directly to
their statement with a little bit more
in-depth
information about the types of genetic
conditions that they feel
meet the criteria for both being
understandable and treatable in a format
that is consistent with
population health testing and the reason
that they believe this
for the cdc tier 1 and sorry to keep you
waiting but we'll talk about the genes
right after the next slide here but they
believe that
over 2 million people in the united
states are at
increased adverse risk for
negative outcomes related to these genes
because they're not being these
conditions are not being appropriately
screened for otherwise
and although there are guidelines for
who should be tested
they're not well known throughout the
entire practice so
here's where an unselected group of
people could benefit
from direct testing of these genes
for these conditions what are they i
know you're waiting on pins and needles
to find out what conditions they
actually are within the cdc
statement the the group has focused on
three different global areas of
diseases one is hereditary breast and
ovarian cancer
two is a colorectal cancer syndrome
known as
lynch syndrome and the third is familial
hypercholesterolemia again these three
because of two main factors maybe three
but the two main factors are we
understand the genes and we understand
what alterations within those genes do
and when we have alterations within
those genes
and in an individual we know how to
treat them next
in order to minimize their risk for
disease
and three i guess if i were to go and
say three we know that these
are significant population health
concerns conditions with population
health concerns
overall and we are better to treat them
ahead of time identify them ahead of
time
than treat them after somebody has come
down with something like breast cancer
colon cancer or familial
hypercholesterolemia
so the genes that we'll be looking at
are the
brca1 or brca2 genes for hereditary
breast and ovarian cancer
for lynch syndrome we'll be looking at
mlh1 msh2
msh6 pms2 and an associated gene called
epcam
and for familial hypercholesterolemia
we'll be looking at the apob
ldlr ldl are associated protein
and pcsk9
so the cdc's pop statement on population
genetics says
for those genes that we've just
discussed we've described
at present these conditions are poorly
ascertained
by the health care system and we know
that early detection could significantly
reduce morbidity
and mortality and once we identify
people who have those alterations
there are clear steps that can be
followed to improve the health
and prevent disease so to answer our
question
does genetics fit within population
health
the answer is yes and to answer the
follow-up question
where do we start well it seems like a
very reasonable position to start with
the cdc
tier 1 genes because it fits these
criteria that are described in the link
in the previous slide
that i provided
besides the benefit to the overall
population that we described
by identifying disease ahead of time and
treating it
before we actually have to treat an
advanced cancer or a cardiac event
we know that in an unselected population
we're going to be able to apply and
provide meaningful health information
to individuals who might not otherwise
qualify to receive
genetic testing so a lot of genetic
testing today requires you to sit with a
genetics professional
and for them to ask you questions about
your family history
and if there's enough of a family
history in that conversation
the genetics professional may decide to
order follow-up diagnostic testing
for a specific condition that is similar
but not what we're talking about here
here we're talking about
all comers doesn't matter what your
family history is
you just get this screening test done if
we don't find anything
we'll have a conversation about what
that means if we do find something
we can then take appropriate next steps
so this availability of testing for
everyone
is an opportunity for them to get tested
when in the clinic they may get missed
because they don't have a strong family
history or they're adopted and they
don't know their family history
and through this experience we believe
that these types of interactions will
really help increase the genetic
literacy
of the general population so when they
go beyond just a screening curiosity
and they have some type of real hardcore
event that they want to discuss with
their care provider
they've already interacted through this
type of mechanism
and they have a base understanding it
based vocabulary and knowledge
to share in dialogue with their health
care provider
okay so let's share just a couple of
examples that show how this
is being done in the clinic
the mayo clinic is partnering as i said
earlier with the helix laboratory to
launch
our own population genetics testing
program
within this program which we call
tapestry
we call it tapestry because we wish
and desire and aim to
weave the consumer and patients genetic
information
with their rich medical history in that
woven fabric together creates their
health tapestry
to help us identify conditions they may
be at risk for
immediately but then also as time goes
on
provide us with a resource that we can
go back to over time
to help understand their disease or help
create tailored treatments for them
within this tapestry study though we
intend to sequence over
100 000 patients over the course of four
years
described we're doing this in
collaboration with helix
and so we'll be doing whole exome
sequencing in practice
but by following the cdc's guidelines
we'll restrict that whole exome analysis
initially to just the cdc tier one genes
so that we know exactly what we're
dealing with
and we know exactly how to train our
clinicians
in the next steps that will need to be
taken in case they have any participants
who turn up to be positive
over time we know that not that
knowledge will expand
and we'll then look at those additional
new genes to see if we can expand some
of the valuable information
that can be shared back with the
participant
our rationale for doing this is number
one um
state of the art for patient care we
believe
that we're on a trajectory from studies
like this
to commonplace and so we really want to
jump right in and begin using this to
better the treatment of our mayo clinic
patients
we also see this as not just a way to
treat patients today
but a way to create a valuable data set
that again in the tapestry model will
weave
rich electronic medical health record
information
with genomics information and over time
create cohorts that will allow us to
solve
more diseases and that will create an
enduring research
legacy that will fuel mayo clinic
research and discoveries for decades to
come
but most importantly i think we'll be
able to improve
health outcomes by preventing disease
and not just
treating disease we're very early in the
process so
i want to say that we while we are
enrolling male patients we're not yet
returning results
and we do hope to get to that point
early this year
although uh current situation with the
covet 19 pandemic
will slow us down but it will not
drown our aspirations
another population health study that we
are working on
is the healthy nevada project this is
primarily
a project between renowned health system
and helix mayo clinic is assisting them
in some of the
variant interpretations that they're
finding in their population
but this this study is quite unique
in the way that it gathers individuals
from
the state of nevada and northeastern
california
over half a million people within that
catchment
that happen to be both
multi-generational
and also a diverse population
within that area and so that group
which houses a world-leading
environmental research institute
has a similar goal as the tapestry
program
but they're trying to go after over 250
000
different individuals and use their
information
and their rich medical health
information in order to study that
population both now
and over time
the enrollment of that study has been
phenomenal
the group has enrolled uh over
10 000 people in the first four days
and in the first six months they've been
able to enroll
sequence and return results to over 25
000 people in the package that those
people receive
on the right of your screen you can see
that
helix will return back to them some
regional health ancestry information
they'll learn some interesting traits
but more importantly
they're also going to learn about those
cdc tier one conditions so that's
hereditary breast and ovarian lynch
syndrome
or hereditary colorectal cancer and
familial hypercholesterolemia
when we look at that data over the
first six months in those 25 000 people
we realize that one out of every 75
individuals have some type of alteration
that impacts their life so that's either
a positive result
in fh in lynch syndrome
or hereditary breast and ovarian cancer
the interesting thing that really drives
home the value and the importance
of population health studying is that
over
90 of these people would not be detected
in the regular medical practice
the group has gone back and taken a look
at
the medical records of all of the people
who were identified with positive
alterations
and looked to see if they would have
been able to predict disease
just based on the reasons that they've
been into the hospital
thus far less than 20 percent of these
participants had any documented
suspicion
of an inherited genetic condition in the
emr
and upon follow-up only 40 percent had a
family history relevant of disease
only 20 26 percent of carriers had some
type of manifested disease
with the median age of first
presentation at
60 years old for hereditary breast and
ovarian
45 years old for lynch syndrome and 62
years old for
fh and on the very far right of the
panel i think
what you can see in this kaplan-meier
curve
is in red people who turned out not to
be carriers
and their health over age versus
those in blue who are carriers and their
health
over age if you draw that line back to
an
area of where you can't really tell a
difference between the population you'll
see that that's about
the age of 30 years old and what that
suggests
is if we would have tested these people
not in their 60s or beyond but if we
would have tested them before 30 years
old
we would have been able to put into
place other
types of care that were either
prophylactic or
heightened monitoring that may have
helped catch their disease
before they had some type of negative
outcome
again suggesting that prevention
is better than treatment
not that you can't not that you don't
have to do both but prevention
is more valuable than treatment alone
okay so i think through that we
understand what population population
genetics
testing is we've shared some examples of
a couple projects that are being run by
mayo clinic and renowned health
now i want to discuss with you some of
the
some of the uh trickier parts
that go into building a program like
this
so i think one of the main challenges
is understanding in a population health
screening
approach how do we do variant
interpretation
we also have to take some consideration
some time to consider
what it means to set up an effective
program and what needs to be put in
place
in order to establish an effective
program and then of course
none of this is without risks so let's
take a peek
at some of the risks but first i'd like
to say a couple words about variant
interpretation
it's been a couple nice papers published
that look
at the space of genetic testing
without a clinical condition
or clinical indication for testing we've
called this
elective genomic testing and we've
talked a little bit
about not just how to do variant
interpretation
but how do you design the the right
assay
for a population health study in my day
job
i typically work within the clinical
diagnostic lab
and within that laboratory we have
people who come in
with really strong family histories of
disease
and in that cohort
we want to use what i call a leave no
stone
unturned approach where we really
use multiple methods in order to
identify alterations
and we comb through every last piece of
literature
to understand all variants that we find
within that individual
to know whether or not they have disease
or not
that's not rapid and it's not cost
effective
so what can we do in a population health
screening
modality that allows us to look at
the most likely suspects in a
rapid and cost effective manner
one of the key pieces to that is
to eliminate the need to interpret
variants of undetermined significance or
vus's
these are the most difficult variants to
evaluate
and they're also very difficult
for clinicians to know how to
how to change or manage their patient
health care
following the receipt of a vus report
so when you're talking about an
otherwise healthy population
we don't want to make it difficult for
clinicians to use
we don't want to cause a lot of undue
follow-up assays and testing
so we believe that you need a higher
level of certitude
when reporting in population health
testing
or in elective genomic testing
good news there are guidelines for how
to do this
it's not a direct corollary or overlap
but the acmg created recommendations
back in july of 2013 that described
what to do when you're doing large
genomic sequencing studies
and you find an incidental finding
this is a finding that is not the reason
why you were originally performing the
sequencing
so let's just say for example we're
doing
whole exome sequencing on an affected
child
a healthy mother and a healthy father
and through
that sequencing to try and identify why
the child is sick
we find out that the mother is a carrier
of a brca1 or 2 mutation hereditary
breast and ovarian cancer
well the acmg policy statement said that
if they opt to find out about secondary
alterations or secondary findings
you should report that out but when
you're reporting that out
only report out pathogenic and likely
pathogenic variants
or for some of the conditions on the
list really only sticking to
known pathogenic variants so that
while they weren't expecting this result
the clinician
and the patient know that for certain
there's action that can be taken to help
treat advise take the next steps for
this individual
if we were to report back a variant of
undetermined significance
it creates a lot of alarm a lot of
caution
and you know can be a very difficult
situation
for both the care provider and the
patient to navigate so
the help from the acmg in these types of
tests say
stay away from vus's focus on what's
known to be pathogenic
or likely pathogenic and that's the line
of certitude that you need to have
in a population health type study
some considerations um who should have
this test done
well i believe that everybody should and
i do believe that at some point soon
everybody will it's most impactful right
now when limiting it to things like the
cdc tier one
to adults under 30 or 40 years old
before they've manifest some of these
diseases so if we find them
we can go through heightened
surveillance or we can do other
prophylactic measures
in order to make sure that they don't uh
succumb
to the more advanced and aggressive
stages of these types of diseases
if we were to have a conversation around
pharmacogenomics or pgx as it's
abbreviated in this slide
we can see that the numbers here are
vastly increased so
uh pharmacogenomics relevant findings
are in about 99
of all of us and as you know as we age
we take more medications
so the age at which these types of
studies would be beneficial
uh is anywhere from you know under the
age of 40
all the way to over the age of 80 years
old and plus
as the number of medications go up you
want to know
how your body metabolizes those
medications in order to avoid any type
of adverse
reaction the big question that we get is
who will pay for it this all sounds
really interesting
but what's it going to cost a lot of
direct-to-consumer testing in the
beginning has
been self-pay personal individuals have
paid for this
but my belief is that that type of
consumer testing is on the decline
and people are actually going to notice
that it's the health systems
and the insurance providers themselves
that are most
interested in better managing their
populations
and when they do that there are cost
savings to the overall program
so significant that they will be willing
to pay for it themselves
i don't think anyone's going to make
this type of testing mandatory
but it's certainly going to get to the
point where
if you want it i believe your provider
will pay for it
the reason for that i think is pretty
simple and it really comes down to
how society overall benefits from
these types of proactive health care
decisions
you can see and we all know that
prevention
is worth over a pound of cure
and this very eloquent although
mathematically very challenging to get
through
article here from the journal of health
economics really applies
mathematics to really describe the value
of disease prevention versus treatment
and at the end of the day it's no
surprise they clearly show
that while treatment and cures are very
important to prolong
life for people later in their
later in life and later in the stages of
their
conditions preventing those conditions
from the outset
are far more effective both from
long-term health benefit and from a cost
perspective
than actually acting in a more reactive
fashion
so clearly these types of tests
proactive tests
are going to benefit society broadly
by both increasing quality of life life
expectancy
but also reducing the cost of care
it's not all ponies and rainbows i'll
freely admit that
although as you could tell i'm a pretty
uh ardent supporter of population health
some of the fears that i worry about are
the false sense of of health security
the i i don't need any colonoscopies
because i took this preventative health
test
and i don't have quote unquote the gene
for breast cancer or in this example
for colorectal cancer and that's just
not true
remember we went back we talked real
briefly about
the the uh the completeness of the test
in the diagnostic laboratory we leave no
stone unturned
in the screening application we're doing
the best that we can to find
the lion's share of variance but
certainly
we're not leaving no stone unturned also
from an interpretation perspective
we talked about how we're not returning
any vus's
most vus's will remain enigmas
for a long time but some of them are
actually very
important and will be elevated to
pathogenic alterations or likely
pathogenic
alterations over time so
those two reasons alone allow you to see
that there is
a bit of incompleteness in these types
of tests
not in a negative way again we couldn't
do population health
if we tried to leave no stone unturned
and report all vus's
pathogenic and likely pathogenic
variants
but there is a small chance that
somebody who who tests
negative by these types of screening
tests still have an alteration that
could not be identified
so we need to be sure to let people know
that even though they didn't have a
positive test result
they should abide by standard population
testing guidelines for
the standard screening protocols like
self-breast examinations
or colonoscopies after a certain age
or talk with your physician about your
cardiac health and
whether or not you need to be put on a
statin don't just rely on the genetic
testing
another thing that we should be
concerned about is uh genomic
discrimination
i think that's very real uh it's a very
real concern
i should say that people have but
luckily we have
we have laws in place in the united
states that help to protect people
against any type of uh of genetic
discrimination from your employer and
that would be the genetic information
non-disclosure act or gina
the other concern that we hear about
frequently is data security
how do i know that your system isn't
going to get hacked and all of my
genetic information is going to be out
in the open
well for the mayo clinic at least all of
these types of studies
treat any of the information as if it
were any other
medical record data point and this is
something that mayo clinic has been
doing for over 100 years
we feel very strongly that your genetic
information is no different so
it gets treated with the same type of
of attention and security that any other
medical health information would be
managed
here at the mayo clinic and then from a
privacy perspective
again from a mayo clinic perspective you
know this will vary by
program from institution to institution
but a lot of academic programs are not
interested in selling your data to third
party
providers or pharmaceutical companies
for research
really is their mission to advance their
own
internal research to help make
discoveries and
help cure diseases
so in closing i'd just like to wrap up
with saying
that there's a very strong potential
here to shift the healthcare equation
from
prevention uh to prevention
over treatment ounce of prevention is
worth a pound of cure
i believe that this is going to become
the standard of practice we're
engaging and many across the country and
globe are engaging
in these types of studies to to prove
that fact
but it will eventually become the
standard of practice
i think the another challenge that i
didn't describe in the previous slide is
that education continues to be
a top concern and priority we need to be
thinking about
not just how we educate the consumers so
we can raise their genomic literacy
but also how do we educate the
caregivers
so that they feel comfortable with this
information
when they're sitting down with their
patients and their consumers
this can all be a little bit stressful
because we don't like
change we like to figure out our lives
and then get very efficient and rapid
in managing a routine but the fact of
the matter is
is the only constant things in life are
change so
let's embrace that journey with that i'd
like to thank you for your attention
and really just welcome you to ask any
questions that you might have about this
talk
or other population health or diagnostic
genetic testing questions you might have
my email is listed at the bottom please
stay
safe and we're all going to get through
this
better times are in front of us thank
you very much and enjoy the rest of the
virtual sessions